I broke my neck I beat cancer I'm going
to real this is the first time that
women's rugby will be in the Olympics
I'm Jillian putter and I play rugby for
Team USA rugby in particular is a very
good life lessons teacher so when you
get tackled you have to get back up no
matter how hard it is I'm gonna give up
I broke my neck
crying rugby in 2010 but when I was hit
I felt and I heard just pop pop pop pop
pop and I knew immediately something was
wrong when the doctors came in and told
me I might not ever be able to play
rugby again I like tried to silently cry
for a while I went through this like
period of allowing myself to be upset
and then being like get it together
Gillian like you can be strong in this
moment there was about a year between
when I broke my neck and when I was able
to get back on the field with my team
and then in a June of 2014 I was
diagnosed with a very rare soft tissue
cancer I had chemo and radiation for
seven months and I lost about 20 pounds
throughout the treatment I was actually
able to work out and that was something
that I was pretty adamant about
thankfully the chemotherapy worked and
I'm cancer-free but it could have easily
turned the other way and I don't think I
could even imagine what that would be
like but I would hope that I would still
have that attitude of never giving up
and rugby was instrumental and getting
me back to where I am today the rugby
community there really helped me stay
positive and keep working out keep that
fire to say I'm gonna be back and I'm
gonna be ready for it
you